Guten Tag, Aktaq ist mein Name und ich bin hier erst.
So als möchte ich ein paar Fragen Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihrer Beschwerden.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Guten Abend, Herr Dr.
Oh ja bitte, bitte, aber machen Sie bitte schnell.
Ich habe so starker Schmerzen seit zwei Stunden.
Das ist schlimm.
Oh.
Bitte Sabut.
Bitte?
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Julia Ganza.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname langsam stabilieren?
Gustav Anton, Nordpol, Zeppelin, Emil Richard, Ganza, Julia Ganza.
Genau. Wie alt sind Sie vor Ganza?
Ich bin 26 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 1,64 m und mein Gewicht ist 62 kg.
Das ist Ihr Haushalt?
Mein Haushalt ist Frau Katrin Sorglos.
Können Sie bitte Sorglos, S-O-R-G, L-O-S, Sorglos.
Sorglos.
Okay, genau.
Was ist die Grundswerche?
Ich habe hier vor zwei Stunden einen akuten Schmerz bekommen.
Hier ist ein Hexenschuss, so Schmerz in den Rücken.
Das zieht mir ins Linkebein hinein.
Ich kann nicht stehen, ich kann nicht sitzen, ich kann nicht laufen.
Ich habe schon zwei Ibuprofen genommen, das hilft aber gar nicht.
Das habe ich noch nie gehabt, das ist furchtbar, Doktor.
Können Sie Dosierung ganz schnell?
Zu Hause nur die Ibuprofen 400.
Nur einmal?
Bein habe ich schon genommen, Doktor.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Hier im Rücken, im länden Bereich, und das strahlt über meine Po-Backe bis runter zum Fuß.
Linken Fuß?
Ja, also von Rücken bis zum linken Fuß.
Wie würden diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind sie herstrährend, rücken oder?
Das strahlt über das ganze Bein, das ist wie ein elektrischer Strom.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Im Moment ganz stark, ganz furchtbar, Doktor.
Von 1 bis 10 auf einer Skala?
Ja, ich würde sagen 8-9, manchmal sogar.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit 2-3 Stunden.
Diese Schmerzen hat plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, relativ schnell, so kurzfristig.
Es hat erst ganz leicht angefangen, aber dann ganz schnell schlimm geworden.
Sind die Beschwerden oder Schmerzen mit der Zeit verändert?
Ja, es ist schlimmer geworden.
Deswegen bin ich ja gekommen, Doktor.
Ich habe sie schon 5-mal gesagt.
Es gibt noch etwas, das die Schmerzen nicht mehr verstanden?
Nein, egal, was ich mache, beim Sitz, beim Liegen, beim Laufen, es tut immer weh.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich machen soll.
Beim Bewegen?
Auch schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen werden schlimmer, können Sie mir nicht eine Spritze geben?
Das ist furchtbar.
Ich verstehe, keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ich gebe nur 1 Minute eine Schmerzmittel haben.
Das wäre mir sehr recht.
Ich würde mich sehr freuen.
Haben Sie eine Beschwerde früher gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Sind Sie noch da?
Haben Sie Schieber nach Schweiß?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Das war ganz gut, damit habe ich kein Problem.
Haben Sie gewischt?
Nein, alles stabil.
Platten Sie sie gut?
Normalerweise ja.
Ich hatte nie Probleme, keine Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, alles gut.
Haben Sie allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Das ist ja nicht spekulant.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit krank?
Nein, ich war nicht krank.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Haben Sie einen Unfaller mit?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Regen- oder Gelegenheit?
Nein, nur wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
nehme ich Paracetamol oder Ibuprofen,
aber ansonsten habe ich bisher keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie Bewegungsschränkungen im Moment?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich kann nichts machen.
Ich kann das Bein bewegen und kaum laufen.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Kreben?
Ja, seit einer Stunde habe ich fast kein Gefühl
auf der Außenseite von meinem Bein.
Auch am großen See habe ich kein Gefühl.
Kein Gefühl? Nein, das ist ganz schlimm.
Das fühlt sich ganz komisch an.
Brauchen Sie Frau Ganzer?
Nein, ich hoffe nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich bin Veganerin.
Veganerin? Ja.
Rhythmische Frage, haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen?
Nein, ich habe nichts zu tun.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Studentin, aber ich mache viel Sport.
Wie gern Musik, oder?
Ich bin Leistungssportlerin.
Ich spiele tennis.
Ich mache jeden Tag Sport, mindestens 3-4 Stunden.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das ist.
Ich kann mir das gar nicht leisten, krank zu sein.
Ich habe 2 Wochen Turniere.
Ich darf nicht krank sein, Herr Dr. Simpsen.
Ich muss mich auf die Beine wiederbringen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Ich habe einen Freund, aber wir sind nicht verheiratet.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne alleine.
Allein? Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder? Nein.
Haben Sie eine Erkrankung?
Nein.
Was haben Sie im Urlaub?
Im Urlaub?
Ja.
Vor 2 Jahren war ich im Urlaub.
Wo waren Sie?
Ich war in der Schule.
Wie ist Ihr Tatanrim?
Im Status?
Ja, die Umfuggen habe ich alle.
Wir sind jetzt fertig.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sein könnten?
Nein, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Herr Dr. Helfen Sie mir.
Ich muss wieder auf die Beine kommen.
Ich absoliere.
Ich habe noch keine Informationen.
Ich habe keine VMware.
Ich würde Ihnen denn sehr dankbar,
wenn die Schmerzen nachlassen können,
um wieder tennis zu spielen.
Genau.
Nach dem Medikament
oder
das Sie sich Sorgen machen
um herauszufinden,
herausto findem, was ihnen fällt, werb i so erst eine körpelle unterzuhun und dann könnten
weitere unterzuhunken wie röntgen oder MRT nötigs sein, sobald wir alle Ergebnisse
haben, erklare ich ihnen alles genau und besprechen das weitere mal.
Was ist alles noch heute?
Wir haben eine körpelle unterzuhunken, natürlich, röntgen natürlich, aber dass MRT nötig sein, einen Termin schreiben.
Ein Termin vereinbaren, okay, gut.
Ich hoffe, dass es auch klappt, wunderbar.
Also der Schmerzmedikament war echt gut, kann ich noch eins haben?
Was waren das, was Sie mir gegeben haben?
Ja genau, aber keine Spritze von einer Tablette von Verschrieben, das ist gut für die.
Was war das für eine Tablette?
Zum Beispiel eine Schmerzmittel.
Okay, was war das für ein Schmerzmittel?
Die Schmerzmittelinhalt, die Klophenac, zum Beispiel.
Die Klophenac, ah, davon habe ich gehört, das soll gut sein.
Das habe ich leider zu Hause nicht gehabt, aber das hat mir echt gut getan, vielen Dank.
Gerne geschehen.
Okay.
Haben noch andere Kollegen Fragen?
Entschuldigung, ich vergesse eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sind Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Ja, da habe ich keine Probleme, nein.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig in Ihrem Frauenarzt?
Ja, so alle paar Jahre, aber das liegt jetzt auch.
Danke sehr.
Wie lange war Ihre letzte Periode?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ist es möglich, dass Sie im Moment schwanger sind?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, hat jemand uns noch weitere Fragen?
Ist Ihr Bein belastet oder gerötet?
Nein, ich habe ein Taubweitsgefühl, aber die Farbe ist jetzt nicht auffällig.
Ist Ihr Bein geschwollt?
Nein, ich fühle es schlecht, es ist alles tauch.
Aber geschwollen Sie es jetzt nicht aus?
Nein.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser?
Haben Sie sich etwas getragen?
Von Anfang an.
Ich habe bei mir in der Garage aufgeräumt und da waren zwei schwere Kisten.
Das konnte ich tragen, aber eine Stunde später haben die Schmerzen angefangen.
Vielleicht hängt das auch damit zusammen.
Ich habe es bestimmt aufgeräumt.
Das habe ich vorhin gesagt.
Wenn ich mir sitze, wird es ein bisschen besser, aber zehn Minuten später geht es wieder los.
Dann lege ich mich hin.
Das hilft für einen ganz kurzen Moment, aber dann geht es wieder los.
Es gibt keine richtige Position,
wo die Schmerzen weggehen oder weniger werden.
Würden Sie kürzlich operieren?
Nein, das habe ich vorhin schon beantwortet.
Haben Sie Wasser gelassen?
Ach so, Sie meinen, ob ich mein Ungewollt habe?
Ich muss öfters aufs Klo, aber ich merke,
dass ich Schwierigkeiten habe, mein Urin zu halten.
Es ist auch ein bisschen in die Hose gelaufen, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Okay.
Und verwestern sich die Schmerzen bei der Hochlagerung
oder bei der Tieflagerung?
Das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Darauf habe ich jetzt nicht geachtet.
Okay.
Und ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ist Ihnen eine Schwäche in Ihren linken Beinen aufgefallen?
Ja, das habe ich vorhin gesagt.
Schwäche und Taupaz gefüllt.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, das ist auch schwach.
Also ich merke, die Kraft ist nicht mehr so da wie vorher.
Okay, danke.
Das war eine sehr gute Frage.
Die Frage nach Herrn in Kontinent und Stuhl in Kontinent
und nach der muskulären Kraft.
Sie gesagt, dass Sie haben keine Stuhlgangsprobleme
und Wasser gelassen?
Ja, vorher.
Ich dachte, Sie haben gefragt, ob ich früher schon mal so etwas hatte.
Okay, verwestern Sie.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarast.
Guten Tag, lieber Jonas.
Guten Tag, danke schön.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, für Sie doch immer, Herr Kollege.
Bitte schön, erzählen Sie mal.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen,
die ich gerade in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Sie ist 26 Jahre alt.
Eine Methea ist 64 cm groß.
Und sie ist 62 kg schwer.
Die Patientin stellt sich vor Augen.
Und seit 2 und 2 Stunden bestehender,
plötzlich aufgetretener,
elektrischer Schmerzen in den
Lomberregion und strahlen aus im linken Fuß.
Das linke Bein bis zum Fuß.
Bis zum Fuß.
Genau, linken Bein.
Aber Sie machen jetzt eine Vorstellung an den Oberarzt.
Wir nehmen sich so eine Schmerz.
Wir können direkt hinten haben,
da haben wir jetzt eine Schmerz.
Wir haben jetzt eine Schmerz.
Sie können direkt hinten haben, den Fachbegriff.
Äh, Tibia.
Der Lumboschalgi,
eine istchalgi Formel Schmerz.
Lumboschalgi.
Türkisch ist es nicht?
Siatik.
Echt? Nein, Türkisch ist der Lumboschalgi.
Wie heißt der?
Siatik.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 9 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Die Patientin fügte hin so, dass die Schmerze in Läufer derzeit verschlimmert hatten.
Darüber hin aus erwähnte sie das eine Bewegung, Einschränkung bestünden.
Die Patientin über Anästhesie im Linken fuß,
wie die Anästhesie oder die Hypästhesie.
Was hat sie?
Parästhesie.
Parästhesie?
Okay, genau.
Oder eine Hypästhesie.
Das ist, mal gucken, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Parästhesie und Hypästhesie?
Einfach weiter. Sie hat Hypästhesie.
Die Patientin über Parästhesie und Anästhesie,
sowie Hypästhesie.
Anästhesie, Narcosie.
Das ist etwas anderes.
Und sowie Urnerinkondinenz.
Eine Herreninkondinenz.
Die Fragungen wurden nach Fieber, Narcosie und Systemischen beschwerden.
Die Patientin sei keine Vorerkrankungen und Voroperation.
Ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Ich möchte Konjunktiv 1 benutzen.
Die Patientin war vorher nicht krank.
Sie hat keine Vorerkrankungen.
Und Voroperation.
Okay.
Genau.
Zusätzlich, so den Genantern mit Medikamenten nehmen,
die Patientin gelegenlich Paracetamol und Ibuprofen ein.
Sehr gut.
Sie hat keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Sie ist nicht Traucherin.
Sie tränkt keine Alkohol und Drogenkonsum.
Sie ist Veganerin.
Die Patientin sei Studentin, ledig und hat einen Partner.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Es gibt keine Auffälligkeiten in der Familie.
Sie sei bekannt.
Es gibt keine Auffälligkeiten.
Es sei keine Auffälligkeiten bekannt.
Bekannt.
Es gibt die 6. Doktorwerte.
Es sei keine Bekannt.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik besteht der Verdacht auf eine Levesdistrosion.
Distrosion?
Problapsus.
Problaps.
Und als Differenzien-Diagnose entkommen eine Distortion oder Fraktur wegen mehr Sporttreiben.
Mehr, was? Mehr? Sporttreiben.
Weil sie viel Sporttreiben.
Viel Sporttreiben.
Eine Leistungssportlerin.
Leistungssportlerin.
Und Leistungssport.
Nein, und Leistungssport.
Sie macht viel Sport.
Eine Messle-Q oder eine Sport-Jour, Leistungssportlerin.
Neapur, das ist Leistungssportlerin.
Tennis, Handball, Fußball, das heißt, sie ist Leistungssportlerin und spielt Tennis.
Okay, okay, was haben wir noch?
Was ist Ihre Empfehlung, wenn Sie sagen, Sie hat ein LWS Prolaps oder eine Protosur,
oder eine Protosur?
Wegen des Verdaufs auf eine LWS Prolaps,
führen Sie eine körperliche Untersuchung mit Fokus auf Extremität und Lumberregion durch.
Welche Untersuchung brauchen Sie, welche Diagnostik?
Welche Diagnostik brauchen Sie, um Ihre Diagnose zu sichern?
Ich, die Peranase.
Was?
MRT im Lumberbereich.
Lumbalbereich.
Okay, sehr gut. Punkt.
Kurze Sätze, nicht komplizierte, lange Sätze.
Kurz und einfache Sätze.
Genau.
Okay, und Sie haben jetzt eine Protosur und welche Therapie empfehlen Sie jetzt?
Zuerst möchte ich eine Schmerzmittel verschreiben.
Verschreiben?
Verschreibe.
Möchte ich verschreiben?
Verschreiben.
Genau.
Und dann eine Krankengymnastik oder?
Welches Symptom ist hier wichtig für eine Entscheidung, ob konservativer Therapie oder eine operativer Therapie?
Das ist wichtig, dass eine Anästhesie, eine Perästhesie und eine Konfinanz...
Genau, eine Anästhesie.
Nicht Anästhesie.
Perästhesie.
Perästhesie und Konfinanz.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Inkontinenz.
Wenn Sie eine Harninkontinenz oder eine Sturinkontinenz haben, dann ist es eigentlich eine dringliche Indikation für eine Operation.
Operation.
Ja, genau.
Und dann teckere ich mich mal, ob ich auch...
Eine Fußheberschwäche.
Also eine neurologische Symptomatik.
Genau.
Aber gut, Perästhesie, Hypersthesie ist auch eine neurologische Symptomatik.
Aber das heißt, eine muskuläre Schwäche, zum Beispiel eine Inkontinenz Symptomatik.
Da sind Indikationen eher für eine Operation.
Normalerweise nur Schmerzen oder Hyperspitalin würde man erstmal Schmerztherapie, muskuläre Lacklands, Krankengymnastik, Physiotherapie, muskuläre Entspannung empfehlen.
Man möge mich korrigieren, bitte.
Heute sind viele Fachärzte und Fachärztinnen da.
Ich bin auch nur ein Internist, wie Josef.
Ich bin dankbar, dass Sie noch Fragen oder Ergänzungen haben, weitere Differentialen da sind.
Zentrumwarte ist ein, es gibt ein Zentrum, das ich weiß, ich vergesst nicht.
Kauna equidu, Kauda equina sindrum.
Kauda equina sindrum.
Wann hat man das?
Ich denke, ist es nicht bei kleinen Kindern eher der Fall?
Jetzt meine Patente von 26 Jahren.
Vielleicht meinen sie eine Spinalkanalstenose.
Spinalkanalstenose.
Erwachsene würde man eher so eine Spinalkanalstenose sagen, denke ich.
Okay.
Also Doktor, sehr gut.
Yunus, ist ihr ne Brastikstürer?
Yokab, es ist da.
Danke dir, dass es Allah razoht.